Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren
bobert's Feud has exploded it is pretty
Bonkers what we're about to talk about
um so of course Margaret Taylor green
Lauren bobert two of the most radical
most extreme mag Republicans super
detached from reality super
anti-democratic super dangerous but
despite being similar in those ways
apparently personally they very much
despise one another and we talked about
in the last segment the fact that Lauren
bober is now trying to impeach Joe Biden
and it seems based on that
and some other things that have built up
but that has been or that is for this
story kind of the spark Marjorie Taylor
green is very upset with Lauren bobert
because she feels like Lauren Bowers
copying her or taking her attention very
strange and this built to reportedly a
moment of Margaret Taylor green calling
Lauren bobert
um as The Daily Beast writes and
actually
I'm trying to think about the the radio
and television Affiliates of the David
Pacman show I'll just say for this story
Little B word okay you I think you can
figure out what that is uh this is from
The Daily Beast marjor Taylor green
calls bober a little B on the house
floor the messy feud between two of Maga
world's biggest stars burst into public
view on Wednesday when representative
Margaret Taylor green called
representative Lauren bober a little B
to her face on the floor of the house a
U.S House of Representatives the angry
exchange came as the two lawmakers have
been swiping at each other
over there competing this is so no
they're competing resolutions to him
preach President Joe Biden I want to
impeach-bited no I want to impeach bite
it but tensions came to a head on
Wednesday after bobert leveraged a
procedural tool to force a vote on her
own impeachment resolution we talked
about that in the last segment within
days undercutting Karine who had offered
her own resolution but not with the
procedural advantages of forcing a boat
look at yourself Maga look at yourself
in the mirror
uh green apparently cursed out bobert
while the house was Voting Wednesday
afternoon as the two spoke and the
center aisle will look at this video in
a moment of the house floor part of
their interaction was captured on
c-spans cameras uh according to sources
that saw the exchange and a third
familiar with the matter the back and
forth began when bobert approached green
and then seated in the chamber and
confronted her over statements you made
about me publicly all three of the
sources said green called bobert a b one
of the sources said green called her a
little
B so you can take your pick on which one
you think actually
happen not a really big difference to me
apparently green said that bobert copied
her articles of impeachment but
um bobert denies that
so that is as immature and as Maga GOP
as it gets and here's the video there is
no audio of them saying this but we can
just imagine
thank you Congress Converses to the back
off the floor
for what purpose does the gentlewoman
order please
from Florida Mrs Lona
I'll mute the video but you can see
it seems somewhat heated just by what
you're watching on screen but with the
added context of what is being reported
what a moment and you combine that with
what we saw
during the speaker vote where uh Matt
Gates was lunged out by another member
and there's just chaos within this Maga
GOP and is that necessarily a reflection
of how outrageous their policy positions
and rhetoric otherwise are no but it is
interesting that the party with the most
dangerous views also happens to be a
chaotic mess with low character
interpersonally it just so happens and I
think those things tend to coincide that
that's the characteristic of this
movement as well you could never imagine
with all the differences Democrats will
have you remember there was a big divide
between Joe manchin and Progressive
Democrats during kind of the build back
better debate era and you can never
imagine something like that happening
there's a level of seriousness
professionalism and maturity
within the Democratic party that
apparently is just completely
evaporating within the Republican Party
pretty wild and it's all over
their argument over who should get the
attention I guess for
um impeaching Joe Biden make sure you
are subscribed to my YouTube channel if
you want to get more of what you're
getting today Luke Beasley on YouTube
think of your most personal emails if
you're using a free email provider you
should know that they're scanning every
email you send and receive even after
you delete it they're usually using the
data to build a picture of your life to
show you ads which many find creepy our
sponsors start mail never scans or
tracks your emails privacy is what comes
first and unlike other email Services
when you delete an email in start mail
it is gone forever it also protects your
data by blocking tracking pixels and
emails which companies and hackers can
use to track you you can create
unlimited email aliases to protect your
identity and cut down on spam you can
encrypt every email you send even if the
recipient isn't using encryption start
mail gives you 20 gigs of storage that's
more than you get on Gmail and it only
takes a few clicks to migrate all of
your emails and contacts over to start
mail go to startmail.com Pacman to get
fifty percent off your first year that's
only about two bucks a month the link is
down below